السلام عليكم انا ايه يسري خريجه صيدله دي
معلومه مش مهمه خالص النهارده
المهم النهارده النجاح احكي لكم عن حكايه
كده او سيناريو تقريبا مره كل حيات كل
حيات كل واحد فينا انا في يوم من الايام
اتفاجئت ان انا ابقى عندي اخ صغير دي طبعا
من اجمل النعم اللي ممكن اي حد يمر بها
يعني حاجه جميله جدا اخيرا يبقى عندك اخ
تمام حاجه صغيره كده جميله هنلعب بها
والدنيا هتبقى لطيفه ومنقضي وقت لطيف شفت
حاجه غريبه جدا ان مش احنا بنلعب البيبي
ده تقريبا هو اللي بيلعب بينا يعني المهم
تمر الايام والبيبي ده يبقى ههه
البيبي ده يبقى عنده سنه او سنتين
[موسيقى]
يبدا كده يتعلم الحركه والمشي ويبدا بقى
مع تعلمه الحركه ده كل حاجه في البيت
حرفيا بتتحرك معه هو حرفيا ماشي في البيت
كده يجوله في الارض عبثا يعني يا ابني انت
بتعمل ايه بس فهمنا شكل الشقه طبعا عندنا
اختلفوا بقى بالشكل الظريف ده يعني ده ايه
ده يعني بالنسبه لي كنت اصغر من كده مش
فاهمه هو ليه الكائنات دي مزعجه كده
فساعتها والدتي قالت ان هم في سن اسمه سن
الاستكشاف اللي هو ايه يعني احنا مش فاهمه
حاجه ده كائن لسه جاي للعالم جديد ولسه
بقى بيحاول يستكشف ايه الناس دول وايه
الحاجات اللي حوالينا دي كل حاجه حوالينا
بالنسبه له غمضه وهو بيحاول واحده واحده
كده خطوه خطوه مع نفسه يفهم ايه الدنيا دي
تخيل ان الشبر ونص بتاعنا الصغير ده بيعمل
عمليه من اعقد العمليات على كثير مننا
تكبار بيعمل عمليه بحث علمي متكامل
الاركان
فمثلا هتلاقي ان اول خطوه بيعملها او اول
ركن في العمليه البحث العلمي هو عنده
مشكله وعنده حاجه غامضه هو فضوله اللي
جواه بيحاول يدور عليها وثاني حاجه هتلاقي
عنده ادوات بحثيه دقيقه
وهي الحواس بتاعته فتلاقيه بيتعمل بذكاء
مثلا لما يكون سامع صوت تلفزيون او
كمبيوتر ويقعد يركز فيها كده هم بيقولوا
ايه وايه اللغه اللي انا مش فاهمها دي او
مثلا لو لقى حاجه في الارض وبيحاول يذوقها
او حتى يلمسها ويحاول يتعرف عليها الغريب
بقى ان هو مش بيحاول كده تجربه عشوائيه
كده والسلام لا ده طلع الباشا بيسجل
ملاحظات كمان وبيطلع نتائج فهتلاقيه مثلا
لو ده حاجه في مره وطلعت طعمها حلو او كده
هيطلب ياخدها تاني ولو هديته دوا وطعمه ما
عجبهوش لو اتنططت قدامه مش هياخد
طب وبعدين فطلع ان دي دي فطره احنا لسه ما
علمناش البيبي ده يعمل حاجه هو بس بيعمل
الحاجات دي هو اتولد بها كده هي فطرت ربنا
اللي حطاها فيه هي طلعت كده لو
ركزنا في السيناريو ده شويه هنلاقيه نفس
السيناريو اللي الانسان عمله اصلا اول ما
نزل على الارض اول ما الانسان نزل وعاش
ككيف مان او انسان
وابتدى كده يكتشف الارض حواليه فيمشي شويه
ويلاقي شويه نباتات او اشجار وشويه تانيه
يلاقي شويه حيوانات وهو حاسس بالجوع هيبدا
مثلا يجرب النبات ده ويحاول يشوفه اذا كان
ينفع للاكل وطعمه بيبقى كويس بالنسبه له
فيعتمد عليه كمصدر غذاء ولا لا ونبات ثاني
جربه ويحس ان هو
لا طعمه ما عجبنيش النبات ده مضر وعمل لي
صداع انا مش هستخدمه تاني وهكذا ويبدا بقى
يشوف لو في حيوانات بيصطادها او ويبدا
يتعرف واحده واحده على البيئه اللي حواليه
شويه انسان الكهف ده
اثناء حركه
حجرين اوضتين كده في بعض ان طلعت شراره
كده وساعتها اكتشف ان في شراره طالعه او
في نار طالعه ساعتها لقى ان النار دي
وسيله جديده هو ما كانش يعرفها قبل كده
فابتدى يجيب الاكل اللي كان بيجمعه من
البيئه حواليه ويحطه على النار دي وابتدى
يلاقي مثلا ان طعمه بقى احسن مكان بياكله
كده الاول فابتدى يعتمد على النار كاداه
لتحضير الطعام والطبخ
واعتمادها لغايه دلوقتي هي الطريقه اللي
احنا بنطبخ فيها
كل السيناريوهات دي بتقول ان الانسان
خان باحث بالفطره هو بس دي طريقته ان هو
يتعرف على الكون من حواليه
كمان انسان الكهف لما اكمل بعد شويه نشتم
بس بيبصها للبيئه على انها اكل وشرب ده
كمان كان بيعتمد عليها كدواء فمثلا يحاول
يلاقي في البيئه اللي حواليه دي لو هو
عنده مغص حاجه تريحه فمثلا اتكتبت الكتب
القديمه او اللي بيسموها دلوقتي الطب
الشعبي او التراديشنر ان مثلا ان شرب
النعناع بيريح في المغص
هم لا وكده لا وكده بس بالتجربه ما كانش
يعرفوا ليه النعناع بيريح او بيعالج المغص
ما كانش عندهم دليل بس اتكتب واتستر في
كتب الطب الشعبي واللي كانت من اهم
مصادرنا النهارده او لاي عالم نبات انه
ياخذ معلومه دي ويدور بعد كده هو ليه
النعناع كان بيريحهم لما كان يبقى واحد
عنده مغص وابتدي بقى يحلل الاكل
والمواد اللي موجوده في النبات ده وفي
النعناع ده ويشوف ايه فيها بالظبط اللي
ممكن يكون كان بيعالج المغص ده تمام ويجي
بعد كده مثلا واحد صيدلي
يحاول السيتونتيه بالظبط ويحطها في كبسوله
وبعد كده يديها للمريض
اللي عنده مغص تمام طيب يعني دي كده بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم بدايه الخلق دي الفطره
اللي احنا خلقنا عليها هو ان احنا بندور
في البيئه اللي حوالينا عشان نلاقي حاجه
تساعدنا او حاجه تخلي حياتنا اسهل احنا كل
يوم بنعمل كده بس بيختلف واحد فينا عن
الثاني
في تخصصه يعني مثلا
يعني مثلا في حاجات معينه ايه ايه الحاجه
اللي بالنسبه لي بتخلي افكاري تلمع فيها
فزمان قالوا من كانت له فكره له في كل شيء
عبره يعني مثلا لو جينا ندي مثال على
القاعه اللي احنا قاعدين فيها دي النهارده
ومثلا انا شخص نجار فاول حاجه هتلفت نظري
هنا يمكن الخشب الخشب ده قوي ولا لا
وهيستحمل الناس اللي هتقف عليه ويستحمل ان
احنا نعمل
والدنيا تبقى صلبه وامان وكويس معنا ولا
لا اما بقى لو انا دكتور هفكر من وجهه نظر
تانيه خالص وافكر ان قعده الناس طويله على
الكراسي دي هتكون متعبه ليهم ولا لا
وقعدتهم قد ايه تنفع وبعد كده اقول لهم ان
هم لازم يتحركوا وان القاعده الطويله لا
قدر الله ممكن تعمل جلطات في الرجلين او
في الاطراف
كل ده كل واحد بص فينا من نظرته مش معنى
ان انا ما بصيتش من وجهه نظر النجار معنى
كده ان هو كان اسهى مني او ان انا مش بصيت
من المهندس او الدكتور او هكذا كل واحد
فينا بصها من وجهه نظره من كانت له فكره
له في كل شيء عبره
طيب تجميع بقى الافكار دي الفكره بتاعتي
وبتاعه الدكتور وبتاعه المهندس وبتاعه
النجار كل ده اللي خلق شكل الحياه
المتكامل اللي احنا عايشين به النهارده مش
معنى ان احنا مثلا نفكرنا وجهات نظر
مختلفه
في وكانت ناس بعض ما احنا كده ان احنا
عندنا مشكله او ان احنا مش مركزين
يعني مثلا لما نيوتن وقعت على راسه
التفاحه
وتلاحظ ان هي ليه وقعت لتحت وان احنا
كاشخاص ليه ثابتين على الارض ما بنطفوش
مثلا او ما بنطرش ان دي كانت مشكله وان هو
كان ذكي بس وكل الناس اللي كانت عايشه
ساعتها كانت اغبياء هو بس اللي اكتشف دي
هي بس دي كانت رؤيه فضوله او الزاويه اللي
هو انترستي فيها وجهه النظر اللي هو
اما كل واحد فينا لزاويه وليه نقطه بيبدا
فيها المهم
يركز فيها وهو
هيلاقي في الاخر الطريق بتاعه الطريق اللي
هيسيب به اثر في حياه الناس
طيب لا نتخيل كده بس لثانيه واحده لو حد
فينا قرر يتخلى عن الفطره دي وان هو انا
مش هبحث تاني مش هبص في العالم حواليا مش
هعمل بحث علمي
ساعتها ايه اللي ممكن يحصل
فعشان كده احنا احنا كانسان فطرتنا او
خطوتنا خلقت على البحث دي حاجه انت
بتعملها لا اراديا دي حاجه انت بيكون عندك
فيها شغف بتعمل القرايه فيها وبتكمل بحث
فيها
وبتوصل فيها
العلامه واثر بتسيبه في حياه الناس
فاللي كنت جايه اقوله النهارده ان البحث
العلمي الصعبه الا البروفيسور بيديها لنا
في الكليه واحنا بنكون مطلوب مننا ان احنا
نقدم كده ورقه علميه مليانه مصطلحات طبيه
معقده وكل ما كانت
المستوى ليس له محل من الاعراب حضرتك يعني
ده لا ينط للبحث بصلاه البحث هو
المحرك والفطره الاساسيه لك عشان توصل
للهدف اللي ربنا خلقك عشانه في الارض هنا
هو
العلامه اللي انت بتسيبها في حياه الناس
البحث
هو الرساله والخلطه اللي ربنا خلقنا عليها
والاثر اللي احنا جايين نسيبه في الارض
قبل ما نمشي كون باحث وعشان تكون باحث
كويس تكون طفل شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]